Na Haneda
Key From the beginning, you make a face that it doesn't
matter.
Hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha, that's why
I
'm
deformed, and
at the
end Nakata still
has many things that I don't have the freedom to do,
Maiki-kun has disappeared,
Draken-kun
always does  I'm going to attack with a book and a cat
I've committed a lot of differences
Tatebontsu Zemo
Net is him Arthur
Bee-san's feelings
[music]
Fujima 5
Please
by Lone
tar
[Applause]
Herb
drawer No,
that's a bad dream.
Naokaah
[Music] It's a
pity
ana
Well then
I
'm a princess